Peter Brown here with a gamespot news
update Xbox one was the best-selling
console in April beating out the
PlayStation 4 no no a statement released
by corporate vice president of marketing
Mike Nichols said that April was a great
month for Microsoft Nichols said as the
best-selling console in the US and April
fans set record April sales and
engagement for Xbox one last month xbox
is also seeing a lot of growth
year-over-year Nichols said Xbox one
console sales in the u.s. increased
sixty-three percent in April 2015
compared to april 2014 an Xbox Live
comparison showed the number of active
Global Users grew twenty four percent
despite Xbox one having larger hardware
sales in April PlayStation 4 had larger
number of software sales sony also
pointed out in its own statement that it
remains the number one console in
overall sales well considering
playstation 4 sold so well in the past
maybe it's not too surprising the xbox
one did so well because everyone already
owns a PlayStation 4 for more gaming
news stay tuned to gamespot com / news